foreign
comes from Dennis in Washington Dennis
writes I have a hundred and forty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
from my MBA ouch my only other debt is
my mortgage and because of the pause I
have kicked the can down the road on
paying my student loans when evaluating
my budgets for when or if they resume
they will I will be miserable yes and it
gives me anxiety yes I make a hundred
and ten thousand dollars at my current
job and I found other full-time jobs
where I can make 100 to 130k I was
thinking again anytime somebody says I
was thinking I know I was thinking wait
for it is it ethical or normal to
consider
I like how he conflated the two is it
ethical or normal to consider doing both
remote jobs at once combined I could
make two hundred and thirty thousand
dollars if not more I figure if I do
this I can pay off my student loans in
17 to 24 months in five years I can be
completely debt free with a net worth of
nearly three quarters of a million
dollars I'd like to hear your thoughts
well first of all it is normal
uh for people to think how can I make
more money and we saw real cases of this
I've talked about it on the Ken Coleman
show certainly during the pandemic and
we've talked about it here on the Ramsey
show as well where there are still
people doing this and uh especially in
technology where they are fully serving
both companies and they are knocking
down two full-time jobs but the other
companies don't know about it so is it
normal yes is it ethical in my opinion
no with the one caveat where I actually
have seen this John and it's extremely
rare So when I point this out I want to
point out it's extremely rare where both
companies did know about it and the the
two supervisors or managers were okay
but it's a very rare situation uh in the
in and so it's unethical I call it
professional polygamy ooh Okay so
unless the companies are aware of it in
an okay which is extremely you need to
tell both people you got to tell them
both okay and no one wants to do that no
because you risk a situation there so
it's not ethical it's cheating it's
professional polygamy it's Sister Wives
you pick the analogy uh it's just not
right and and the reason it's not right
is most of the time when you're trying
to pull this off
you aren't making people aware of it now
John I can tell you I've been doing this
long enough
I'm going to anticipate some objections
right now and so let's go through them
one objection is oh wait a second what
if one is during the day and I work one
at night okay great fantastic I still
think both companies need to know about
it I just do and so if you're not
telling them which means you are
withholding from them I believe that
that is unethical that's one objection
well wait a second I can truly get both
jobs done I am truly serving both I all
right again
you're not telling them you're
withholding it's a it's unethical it's
not the right thing to do and uh you can
make a lot of financial sense out of it
I don't think you can make any moral
sense out of it so for me
um yes I understand it it can be done
and it is being done I don't think it's
right
I think the bigger concern here for
Dennis and Washington
my fear for this guy is this he has
created a world
he's created a mess for himself
and he created a mess for himself
probably since he's got a hundred and
forty thousand dollar NBA he's probably
a smart guy and he came it it feels like
the uh the Bro Science the uh he did
some great um Beanie Baby math here and
it's like oh if I do this I'll get my
NBA and then they're gonna then they're
gonna
um just cancel out the loans and then
suddenly it's three years later from
this big promise
and like we've been telling you and
telling you it hadn't come through yet
and now people like Dennis are starting
to realize oh I may have to pay all this
back that's right and the other day
um on the Ramsey Show David I went
through an article and again hat tip to
the great Tyler Cowan from marginal
Revolution
again I was stunned so there's there's
two different Loan Servicing paths for
it if you will one of them is the loans
the student loans are made by the
government the other is made by Banks
and guaranteed by the government so when
the pause came in
the government only has authority to
pause one of them that's not the other
one that's correct so you've got an
instant for researchers an instant
randomized control group some people got
it paused and some didn't and when they
went and studied those like right now
they just studied them and this was an
economic white paper out of DC these are
the top of the top guys I love this
stuff
what they found was those that did not
receive a pause there were not
additional delinquencies
they I I wish there was a more fancy way
to say this they figured it out they
looked at reality and said this sucks
and they figured it out when their jobs
were going away when they had couldn't
work they figured it out
the other folks who got the pause
increased their debt by approximately
five percent how per household that's
Madness it's crazy because what they did
was they had extra liquidity in their
home extra cash and they put they use
that for down payments on cars on new
houses or on like other they spent that
money oh yeah and it propped up the
economy for a second and then it further
trapped those people down down the
stream right so dude you've created a
mess for yourself and I wish there was a
hack here Tyler
there's one hack and that is to get a
machete and head into the jungle and
carve yourself a path man and that is
paying the stuff off it's going to take
you a long time because you dug yourself
a huge hole or find a job that pays you
250 000 in an ethical way right all
right I want to stay here okay I want to
go back to what you just said yep with
the white paper yeah is it a lot of
people listening and watching brand new
to this whole discussion and I think
this is a psychology thing and I know
you know it so I'm gonna so I want to
dig all right so the people that were
believing
shall we say hoping
wishing I'm giving you three
psychological states that Uncle Joe or
congress were going to wipe their debt
clean they ended up spending more money
what is going on psychologically there
when someone knows they got debt hanging
over them they are hoping wishing
believing but they still go out and take
on more debt or they spend more what is
happening in The Human Condition there
there is a you take a breath
and the fear of I'm about to get eaten
goes away okay and you just instantly
fall back to homeostasis you go back to
the way things work and the way things
were was I bought whatever I wanted
whenever I wanted it we also didn't take
into account there was a pause and but
people were one year into the degree so
they kept going to school taking out
more loans and more so the whole thing
was a is a mess but I think there was a
group of people the world started
shutting down and remember the dominoes
falling and everything impacted this
this this this and this and this
I remember that it was scary it was
scary
and then they came in and said you don't
have to pay this month you don't have to
pay indefinitely
and everybody exhaled
and then someone said hey look at this
new car and we are off to the new next
new thing
the other folks who did not have a pause
didn't have that luxury they had to
figure out the scary reality they were
in okay so what happened there then
chemically and maybe it's not chemical
but what's going on in the brain where
you're in a fight or flight or you're in
a you're in a state of because you said
they relaxed the people that's right so
what happened is I just want our
audience to understand that this money
game we got to understand how we're
wired and when we sense some relief is
that what happened they were like oh I
may not have to pay it and then they
just said I got options now in the
moment you have options okay every
business in the world comes after you
well because they know you got cash in
your powers and I'm not better I'm not I
can't defeat the the neuroscientists and
the tech folks and the sales people who
have all banded together to right pump
me full of ads every day I can't beat
them and so the moment I exhale whom
yeah when I'm looking at math and I
can't feed my family yeah then I can
defeat Those ads yeah because I gotta
feed my family right it's a scary moment
so my takeaway my Layman takeaway is
when it comes to debt you cannot relax
on it that fight or flight is a good
thing you need that intensity to be able
to push through the Temptation that's
what I'm taking a look yes absolutely
all right there it is there's psychology
around money folks let's not forget
beautifully I know